here for a reaction former HUD secretary
the founder and chairman of the American
Cornerstone Institute Dr Ben Carson uh
Dr Carson thanks so much for joining us
um I got to tell you some of the
guidance along the way uh 54 years is
sitting in that one see it's just too
long we talk a lot about term limits for
members of Congress there should be term
limits for senior members of the uh
Administration as well don't you think
well don't get me started on term limits
but uh I will say I've known Dr fauci
for for decades we belong to some of the
same organizations we've been honored
together and he's made some very good
contributions to medicine particularly
in the area of AIDS but I was on the
task force the coronavirus task force
with them and and had a number of
disagreements you know particularly when
it comes to Therapeutics
and uh because people disagree it
doesn't make them anti-science so I
think that it's something that he would
do well to clarify he will have an
opportunity to clarify that he will have
an opportunity before the congressional
committees to talk about many of the
statements that were made that perhaps
vary a little bit from veracity and you
know I think one of the big problems
that we have right now is people have
lost faith and our Public Health
authorities and the way that we've
handled covet has been a big part of
that not talking about natural immunity
which we've known about for hundreds of
years since the Civil War and uh the
tremendous benefit that it uh conveys to
people I think that was a big mistake
talking about vaccinating kids when they
have uh almost a zero percent mortality
and very little morbidity from it at
least explain to people why should they
get vaccinated if they're a child and
they're not doing that and that would be
something that would be very helpful in
terms of restoring trust if they have an
explanation but I think the area where
he could be most helpful
is to really condemn the collusion
of big Tech and some of our federal law
enforcement agencies and suppressing the
opinions of people who disagreed with uh
with the CDC and with some of the
recommendations that he put forth you
know that is not only a problem with
medicine that is a problem with freedom
in our country one of the fundamental
pillars that made this into a great
nation we can't allow that kind of thing
to stand so he has an opportunity I
think
to rectify some of the mistrust and
perhaps enhance his legacy
well I think that is one of the
fundamental problems is the LA the loss
of trust because you're right when we
need the CDC when there is something
that's going rampant right now they've
lost so much trust I think so many
people are so skeptical that they won't
necessarily listen and that's because of
the way Dr fauci personally handled it
you know every time he's on Vanity Fair
and doing all these media interviews and
writing a book and making five million
dollars during covet a lot of people
just don't understand that
no I'm sure they don't and and maybe a
little humility just a little bit would
go a long way you know I was wrong uh
but we've learned some other things
why is it that people in the political
Arena have so much difficulty saying
those words
yeah I I think it's a great point a
little just an ounce of humility along
the way and saying you know we learned
from this I mean the United States of
America that's who we are Dr Wright we
are self-critical but we do it in order
to make the world a better place and I
got to tell you doctor I'm a huge fan of
what you did and how you did it I think
you personified how to do these types of
things we need more of that in our
public servants not less so thanks for
joining us tonight I wish I could talk
to you for the full hour but I hope you
have a wonderful wonderful happy new
year thanks for joining us tonight
thank you you too Jason thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else